alors où est le temps mais diriger ça
tout seul vas-y c'est cool je t'écoute
wen
custom neuf mois dès que j'ai essayé de
lire la clé ça fait griller mon ordi on
dirait qu'à la glace il encore alien
bien joué j'ai jamais vu une clé c'est
bien protégés c'est du haut niveau
d'encryptage je n'arriverai pas à
lattaquié fouras qu un hacker en
freelance et du coup au peuple ça fera
car tu te rends compte de la quantité de
conneries qui sort de la bouche
le gars est une voiture mais on peut
s'estimer heureux parce que il a un gros
ego il a signé son oeuvre qui est assez
con pour faire ça ce type
l'expert de miami on dirait le souci
tout pourri jack reacher c'est hyper
drôle c'est que c'est drôle